hello folks this is one of our unplugged
off-the-cuff conversations with
professor gary marcus if you like
content like this please consider
hitting the subscribe button and also
rating our podcast on apple podcasts
enjoy the show so let's be honest folks
professor gary marcus needs no
introduction whatsoever this is his
third appearance on the show a feat only
matched by conor leahy
someone on the diametrically opposite
end of the spectrum from gary professor
gary marcus is a cognitive scientist he
founded robust ai and also the machine
learning startup geometric intelligence
which was acquired by uber so after that
he was a director at uber ai labs he's
the author of five books including
rebooting ai and his professor emeritus
of psychology and neuroscience at new
york university
gary obtained his phd in cognitive
science from mit and as we've discussed
previously he advocates for a four-step
program the initial development of
hybrid neurosymbolic architectures
followed by construction of rich
partially innate cognitive frameworks
and large-scale knowledge databases
followed by tools for abstract reasoning
over such frameworks and ultimately more
sophisticated mechanisms for the
representation and induction of
cognitive models he thinks that
effective cognitive architectures are
likely to look more heterogeneous with
many specialized modules anyway um gary
it's an absolute honor to have you back
on the show welcome thanks for having me
back
amazing well um i want to get straight
to the meat of the conversation everyone
wants to know your take on ilya sudskiva
and the uh the slightly conscious uh
language model i mean you know on what
one day we hear they hallucinate and the
next day we hear they're slightly
conscious so what's your take on it i i
don't see the argument at all for the
being conscious i will i will pause and
say that nobody really has a
consciousness meter or a good definition
of consciousness and so you know it's
like pornography i'll know it when i see
it or something like that we don't we
don't have a clear definition
however by any of the criteria that i
think are interesting i don't think that
it particularly qualifies so there's no
semantic grounding in anything
there is
uh
basically just kind of statistic
mongering over large-scale data there's
no real reasoning over anything
certainly not in a reliable sense
there's no coherence and i think you
could argue that consciousness is about
forming a coherent representation of
reality it doesn't really do that
um and i mean really it's just matrix
multiplication and like i'm not sure why
one set of matrix multiplication you
know possibly a larger set than somebody
else did last week should suddenly
magically cross the threshold so i mean
you could still take a very pan psychist
view the most extreme would be like
rocks are conscious and then okay maybe
you know all neural networks in fact all
computer programs are slightly conscious
but to the extent that the
conversational implicature was that
there was something
surprising about its consciousness
relative you know alleged consciousness
relative to any other system i just
don't see the argument
um are you a computationalist by the way
uh well i guess again we're gonna need a
definition for that what do you mean by
am i a computationalist
well um
do you i mean you know you know like
substance dualism uh is when it's it's
about the irreducibility so whether you
think that the mind could be kind of
like composed entirely of its physical
circuitry and components i mean i like
the phrase that the mind is as the brain
does i i think that you know whatever
our cognitive systems are or a function
of the brain and if you want to be
technical about it the spinal cord and
you get you know you have
um nerve sensation from all over the
body and interesting things going on in
the stomach but i i think that basically
the stuff that we call the mind is is
somehow physically realized for sure
um and you can take a kind of
functionalist view and say that anything
that did the same computations would in
some sense have a similar kind of mind
you know i think those are
reasonable arguments i think a lot of
these arguments suffer because there are
no hard definitions that they're
grounding out in and so
you know ultimately people can have
different definitions i mean take the
word symbol maybe we can talk about that
too like you know there are 40 different
definitions of symbol and whether
something is a symbol system partly
depends on you know what do you mean by
that and where do you want to go with it
and when it comes to consciousness you
know you could take different kind of
views about functionalism depending on
what your definition of consciousness is
and so
it's very hard to like
ground yourself in a fact of the matter
about these things you can ask maybe
more specific questions like is a
particular system self-aware right which
i left out of my litany before and
shouldn't have um
you know
i could make an argument that the gps
system in my phone is aware of its
position and therefore when i ask it you
know how do i get to you know the east
side of town it it makes a computation
based on its current representation so
it's self-aware of where it is in the
physical world and makes good choices
not perfect but pretty good choices
about taking left and right and in fact
it's able to hook up to the web and
integrate information from the web well
gpt can't do that you know gpt can't
look up its position with a gps can't
put that into a computation can't
um can you can't build a representation
of where it is in the world make
decisions accordingly in the real world
so you know maybe my gps system is
actually more uh aware has more
self-awareness
um
than anybody's large language model
because they used to put that in your
pipe and smoke it i mean you know like
you know it's i i say it
half and jest right i mean i don't
really think that i want to attribute
self-awareness in the sense that i mean
it in consciousness to my gps system but
you know that is actually an element of
what you need is is you have to know
your position in space and time lots of
robots have that and lots of
cars nowadays have that but
gpd3 doesn't so like why does it qualify
right i think the um the example you
gave with the gps that that's analogous
to the kind of parlor trick you're
you're talking about with gpt3 but we
spoke with professor carl fristen
earlier and he was saying that you know
for a system to exhibit um intelligent
behavior it needs to be it needs to have
a kind of reflexivity consciousness not
intelligent behavior well he started by
saying um intelligent behavior it needs
to be um a part of a closed loop which
means that you know we were talking
about just the brain but it needs to be
embodied in some sense there needs to be
some slightly zoomed out and reflexive
process
well so i don't think you know gpt
gpt qualifies for that
um i'm not sure that my car example
really qualifies for that in terms of
the like zooming out that you're just
describing so
what the
car navigation system can't really do is
to reflect on the fact that it is a car
navigation system that it's inside of a
car and it probably will forever be
unless somebody performs a transplant
operation i mean there's some level of
like
reflexivity
um if that's the right word reflectivity
i'm not really sure the right word here
um
that the human has for example maybe not
too many other creatures have and
clearly gpt does not have this and i
don't think very much software at all
has this there are some software systems
that can like do some self-checks and
self-diagnosis and stuff like that you
could maybe attribute a little bit of
you know
probably what you really want to do is
to say that there's a bunch of necessary
conditions we don't really know the
sufficient conditions and we certainly
won't know the sufficient conditions
unless we give better definitions of
terms and then on those sufficient
conditions we can say well can a system
represent where it is for example
physically can it make decisions around
that that you know
allow it to use that
um for something functionally so like
you know maybe if you literally just
have the gps without the navigation
stuff from the turn by turn stuff that
i'm kind of
putting as part of the example you know
maybe that's part of it
you know until you actually use that to
make a decision should i go left or
should i go right in in order to get to
point b you know
that's you know a lower level or
something like that but you know we
probably don't want to wind up with a
conclusion even that the fanciest
navigation system you know the ways with
traffic recognition or whatever you
probably still don't want to argue that
that has self-awareness and you know
something else that you and i have
talked about is the sociology i think of
of ai right now you know the fact that
elias at scaver said this about gpte
well i could have said that about you
know
about waze and it would have been
ridiculous and nobody would have picked
up on it but because of you know the
power dynamics of silicon valley and
blah blah blah um you know
one one of those comments would get
picked up and the other probably not so
i mean i could for fun you know at least
make the claim um that ways is at least
a bit closer to consciousness than gpt
three and i do not see the argument
right
so
that's a funny point but i guess you
said that software is not not conscious
there's no software today that's
conscious
agree with that but will so will it be
possible just to narrow down
the computational you know framework
will it be possible in the future to
have
software running in silico that's
conscious or is there some barrier that
will make that not possible and it
really depends on your definition i
think the closest thing
that we've got now are robots and there
are lots of different robots um but like
let's let's take you know a boston
dynamics robot since people know them
like spot
so spot has some
representation of where it is
uh there's i i don't know the current
state of the software but you know i saw
it a few years ago and you know there's
some degree to which you might be able
to set it to do certain things
autonomously
and you know so there's a recognition of
awareness it has a set of
decision-making things around that
you could i mean if you really wanted to
argue that something out there was
conscious and you know maybe that would
be closer but in other ways you'd say
it's really unsatisfying i mean it
doesn't have any ability really to
reflect for example on its goals you
know the user sets a very narrow goal
and it pursues that goal like i don't
know the current state of the software
but let's suppose you can say you know
i'm in this part of the room i want to
go to that part of the room in that
sense it's not so different from from
the driving systems um
i don't see more than that i still don't
see what we're getting at with
consciousness like i think that whole
field has problems and the number one
problem is there's you know there's no
gold standard or gold truth as
you know people would talk about in
machine learning you know mostly we just
have i think i'm conscious because i
said so and then like you know
paraphrasing descartes um a little more
in your face version of descartes and
and like we don't get very far after
that i'm guessing you guys on the call
are not deep fakes that you are
conscious but what do i know yeah i'll
tell you a favorite quote by the way
raymond smelling was a logician wrote
some uh great books and he had um
this line about solipsism which is like
this idea that you're the only person
that exists um or i am really my idea of
solipsism probably um that i just
expressed he says sure i'm a solipsist
but then again that's just one man's
opinion
so right
you know how do you get past that how do
you establish ground truth so like a lot
of people would probably think that
their pet dogs are conscious and maybe
they're right and maybe they're wrong
and like if i can't answer that question
firmly how am i going to answer the
question about whether
spot which looks a little bit like a dog
is conscious like you know i can i can
start to make some systematic claims i
think there's a lot of things dogs can
do that spot can't they're probably a
few that spot can do that the dogs can't
um
now i need some criteria
and you know ilia is not a philosopher
it did not offer any criteria he just
said this wacky thing
and do do you um place weight on the
importance of phenomenological
experiences you know like the qualia or
do you do you have more of a declarative
notion of consciousness
i think you should have warned me you're
going to talk about consciousness so i
couldn't oh no so we don't need to know
that's why
you're i'm just kidding you i always
like to improvise on whatever people
give me but um
i i would say that we have not a lot of
clue about what qualia are
but there's a real argument that there's
something there that is to be understood
even if we don't understand it so like
what is it like to feel like red or to
experience an orgasm i'm going to guess
that gpt has neither of those feelings
and i don't see any particular reason to
think that it does
um
the it's inner
its ultimate incoherence is one reason
to think it doesn't right um i mean
there are other reasons i think it
doesn't but but you know if you really
had a qualia
of like let's say feeling like a person
and then i ask you are you a person and
then i ask you are you a computer you
should give different answers because
you have some inner
sense right phenomenological sense if
you are but um i guess i can
give a little hint that i'm involved in
an art project in which i ask gpt
exactly that are you are you a computer
and i forget the order that asks both
those questions are your computer it
says yes are you a person that says yes
like immediately back to back
and you know there's no stable
representation
of anything it's not really in fact
drawing on an interstate at all and
actually as i think about this online
you know an important part of
consciousness for a person i would say
um
is having a cognitive model of the world
doesn't have to be perfect our models of
the world are not perfect and you know
one of the deepest questions that there
are deepest things that philosophy
teaches us i think is that we live in
our own reality we don't have direct
access to external reality all of our
representation of reality is mediated
through our senses and everybody should
know that if they're talking about these
questions um but what i think
follows from that is that you do have a
reality that you have constructed and
that that's really pretty critical and
um it tends to be at least for people a
stable reality it's not perfectly stable
so you can get things like necker cubes
where you're
interpreting your inner representation
of the outer reality actually flips
right it's not stable um you can have
other things you know it's a bird it's a
plane it's superman and so you change
your mental model over time of what that
flying object is and
you know that's not uncommon but there's
a lot of stationarity to our mental
representations of the world and i think
that's part of consciousness is having
those
relatively stationary representations of
the world they're always subject to
update so you know you're playing a
prank on me it actually is deep fake
stuff that you recorded and now i'll you
know i'll have to deal with that and you
can tell me that um so you know it's
possible to change the mental
representation but we have a process of
building a representation and this is in
my own words i think my own way of
presenting it it's very similar to some
things that dennis has said about like
um the the theater of consciousness um
so you you have this
inner thing which you can do
computations over so you you have a
stable representation this goes back to
the introduction you said i you know i'm
someone who emphasizes cognitive models
this is what i mean by it is you have a
cognitive model so like my model right
now i don't know how you'll present this
um in your video but right now i have a
model that says i'm sitting you know in
a room there's a desk there on top of it
is a laptop there's a camera point at me
i see videos of three different people i
don't know if your viewers will see that
um you know you're nodding your heads
which means you understand what i'm
saying i'm trying to communicate
something if you don't nod your head i'm
probably going to try to repeat it and
say it in a different way and i'm
modifying that over over time like are
these guys on my side are they skeptics
you know should i you know should i be
put out there right so i you know i'm
iterating on that model constantly same
thing if i watch a movie like
well i just watched this netflix series
um the title which i cannot fully
reconstruct but stars kristen bell um
and the whole thing is about constantly
changing your mental representations
like you know who's the bad guy is is
she hallucinating is she not
hallucinating what's her mental state
it's kind of about an unreliable
narrator sort of thing um and so the
whole
fun of watching the show is you are
building a mental model you realize that
it's the show has been designed to keep
you on your toes and you're going to
change your model but that model is your
conscious representation at any given
moment so it's i don't know eight
episodes i'm embarrassed i watched them
all and you know so like when you're at
the end of episode two like you have a
different mental model of what's going
on watching that and of course you do
the same thing um in real life and i
think that that's pretty important to
consciousness and there's no way that
any large language model really does
that
that's fascinating i mean um first of
all gary have we ever let you down
you have you can trust us my mental
model on you is firm but you know life
is you know maybe you got a bride
you can always elaborate circumstances
no but you've been good to me that is
part of it
indeed we have it did we have but um no
actually fristen was saying something
very similar earlier so when he started
talking about consciousness he was
saying that well actually there's a kind
of predictive way of looking about it so
you can um you can have a theory of mind
and you can kind of um uh do uh planning
and think about trajectories in the
future and and how other people will
respond to those trajectories and and
that's something which is constantly
it's really evolving if you pause there
for one second and then can maybe finish
the question so
i was just emphasizing
the model in terms of like the current
states of affairs and then i would say
theory of mind is like
a set of mechanisms and nobody really
knows but a set of mechanisms that then
allows you to make predictions across
that current state of affairs and that
includes some long-term stuff like you
know i don't think you took a bribe but
i know sometimes people do and so that's
part of my general common knowledge and
so you know i assign a very very low
probability to it but not zero in this
crazy world in which we live you know in
which you know republican congress
people suddenly change their minds about
certain things or whatever um
so you know there's actually multiple
steps there that was more what i put
under reasoning in a very generic sense
in in the article that you were kind of
alluding to the next decade in ai so
there's like there's this i mean it's
the
lines between these are gray but roughly
speaking we have a set of knowledge um
we have
the background long-term knowledge we
have some kind of knowledge about the
current situation i mean really the
current situation probably is like a
cognitive model of your whole life and
your history and whatever but there's
there's like general knowledge there's
knowledge is particular to you sometimes
people talk about procedural
anti-clarity knowledge and so forth um
and and then there are also mechanisms
of reasoning over those things and that
can include
deduction induction abductions like
inference the best explanation
um so when i make an inference in theory
of mind i've got like some knowledge
from a cognitive model like i'm talking
to you right now that's part of the
cognitive model i'm gauging your
reaction and i've got mechanisms for
like reading your facial expressions
that feed into other things like i'm
trying to model do you understand me
right now um right i mean part of the
skilled teacher or lecturer or podcast
guest is to to you know get that
feedback it's why it's harder to do a
strictly audio podcast than one where
you can see the other person um it's why
i hate doing zoom calls where
everybody's got their camera off but you
can't get that feedback so you don't
know if you're doing a good job or
what's missing or whatever so you're
integrating all of that stuff um in a
good cognitive model and then making all
kinds of inferences like okay now i
think he didn't understand i'm going to
pause i'm going to try to explain that
piece again etc
that's that's fascinating i mean i think
there's two places we can go from here
and i was going to bring up eliza and i
mean melanie
response that are vaguely relevant to
you so i mean we've had conscious
computers since 1965. that was said
tongue-in-cheek right i do not think
eliza's conscious that was a joke but i
mean you know by what criteria right
it's well it's a very human phenomenon i
mean the um the chief scientist at open
air could be forgiven for thinking that
it's slightly conscious but it is a very
human rebooting ai we talked about i
think the phrase was the gullibility gap
and we actually used eliza as an example
but gpt-3 which didn't exist yet would
fall into the same thing the point of
the gullibility gap is we're not evolved
to be able to distinguish machines from
people right i mean this wasn't part of
the environment adaptation there was no
such problem for our ancestors and most
people are not trained to do that and so
we can take a small amount of
intelligent behavior and essentially we
assimilate people into the set of human
beings because there's no other creature
that can do those kinds of things so
your dog cannot do what eliza does i
mean like this is actually not nearly as
smart as your dog but it's easier to
trick somebody with eliza into thinking
you know because it's linguistic in some
sense right everybody your audience i
hope knows about eliza you say you know
how how am i doing or i'm feeling sad
today and it says you know tell me about
your family so like that one little bit
of contingency your dog is never gonna
say tell me about your family and so
people can get suckered into it another
example of the gullibility gap is for
years people have thought that
driverless cars are just around the
corner because they don't really
understand the nature reliable ones that
we could actually use that would
actually be level five and take us from
point a to point b so we've we've had
some version of driverless cars since
like the 70s or something like that
forget when somebody like took you know
first took a car on the audubon and you
know
every time there's progress people get
really excited but it's a version of the
gullibility gap because you see a little
bit of illustration of a behavior that's
very human-like right again your dog
can't drive your car not on the highway
not for one minute don't try it at home
please
um
but you know you get this software that
does it and you think well if it can do
it for a minute wow that's so impressive
it's so different from the distribution
that i expect from my dog and my cat and
my baby um there must be really
something there but if you actually
understand the problem you realize that
there's an enormous gap elon just
tweeted about this yesterday about how
hard a problem is and the reaction from
the rest of us in the community is like
i know right we've been telling you this
for a long time i haven't decided
together whether to post my receipt so
to speak but i have a long discussion of
this on the edge in 2016. maybe you can
link it in show notes um where i talked
about why driverless cars even though we
already had examples of it in 2016 is
really hard because we have this outlier
problems it turns out that it takes a
special kind of mind to be able to deal
with the outliers namely one that can
build a cognitive model of where it's
driving and we don't have that for the
most part a little bit but we don't
really have full-scale cognitive models
so for example elon's system somebody
who posted this recently
would would otherwise
without intervention driving to a human
being holding a stop sign on a pole
right um
if someone actually had to slow down a
car that was running into a human
carrying a stop sign on a pole well
there's no cognitive model
we're not a rich enough cognitive model
in the tesla fsd to be able to recognize
that that is a human carrying a stop
sign that's not something it even knows
how to represent you represented i just
said it a person carrying a stop sign
now you can visualize it you can go look
at the picture and see how close your
visualization is
i could try to embroider it or whatever
and i could tell you that you know the
human was wearing yellow or whatever
so you build a cognitive model
that is compositional it's whole it's a
hole that is unusual
um consisting of parts that are not
unusual um actually a stop sign that's
not in the ground is a little unusual
but you can imagine you pull out the
pole you got the octagon okay i get it
looks like a big lollipop right you got
it in your head now so you have this big
lollipop somebody's holding it now you
have a cognitive model of that well i'm
willing to bet that at least until you
know that maybe they dealt with that
outlier case now but at least until a
few weeks ago when this was discovered
there was no way even to represent in
the system the possibility of somebody
carrying something in fact the whole
verb carry probably isn't represented in
the limited repertoire of the thing
there are some things in its cognitive
model like roads but not a lot more it's
not rich the thing about your cognitive
model system is it's incredibly rich
like i have some headphones here and if
you i mean this is a made-up example but
if you had never seen folding headphones
before then okay you know immediately
you would construct a cognitive model
okay so now there's a thing is folding
headphones you know probably i had never
seen such a thing until x years ago and
then i saw and i was like yeah that'd be
nice because i could stick it in my
backpack you were immediately available
to make the inference that i could stick
it in my backpack even if you hadn't
seen one up until that point i've
questioned because you're hitting on
some really interesting things so so
first off um
i think you would agree that whatever uh
models whatever world models human
beings create they create abstract world
models is that fair
yeah i mean there's probably a mix of
abstraction and you know very concrete
stuff so okay you know i i represent
this room in very
abstract ways of like you know there's a
desk and i can raise and lower it and
then there's specifics like right now
it's at you know 42 inches high or
whatever i mean i'm not that precise
about it but um this is not perfect
example but you know
we're capable both of representing
abstractions like there exists a class
of things that are folding headphones
and this is another really important
thing is types versus tokens these are
my um headphones and i don't want you to
wear them because you know i don't want
your cooties and so i'm going to track
no i get that but i think where i'm
going here is because the compositional
models is what i want to ask you about
because
in my mind at least and what we've seen
so far is that abstraction is the key to
building those compositional models you
know objects that can be placed together
etc
and uh we were talking um you know as
you know with joshua bingio and you
haven't watched that episode yet but a
big part of it is about
these g-flow nets and his his argument
there is that if you have a
compositional tree a flow net
and then you take a neural network and
attach it to that so that it can learn
flow weights such that generates
a generative model that is
recapitulating you know some reward
function or the real world that this is
really a step towards the ability to uh
learn abstract models and i'm just
wondering i mean
you know given that there are caveats
here i'm just wondering what you think
about that that approach of really
trying to learn
compositional models that in a sense or
abstractions of of real world you know
world i can't speak to the details
because i haven't read the paper yet
um
though it sounds interesting is it
published yet yep
it's published
i need to read the paper before i say
too much but i will say that the
abstract characterization of what he's
doing i think is both right and a step
towards neurosymbolic cognition it's you
know it's taking a playbook that is very
clearly understood in the symbolic world
of constructing holes out of their parts
i don't understand the technical details
of how it's done but um that and glom
are both trying to build you know whole
hintons and glom are trying to build
holes out of parts now hinton's model
when i looked at in detail really seems
to me to be a symbolic model that isn't
called that so
in particular what's really driving it
is creating symbolic representations of
the parts which are called embeddings
but are intended to be stable across
context and that's really what a symbol
is so you can think of like you know the
ascii code for the letter a is a certain
you know bit string that is stable and
universally used as a code and that's
the foundation for for modern computers
um and i think hinton's sort of backing
into doing
exactly that i don't know in the
technical details of how g flow works
for example
what the holes are and what the parts
are and what the relations are um
whether you wind up with tree structures
that you can traverse which would be you
know the kind of classic symbolic thing
so you could imagine for example that
you
sort of have a symbolic version of all
of this but you can do some interesting
differentiation um across that and that
could be interesting um what i've always
been committed to is that you have to
actually be able to
um pull out the parts from the whole and
be able to analyze what the hole is in
terms of the parts if he can do that in
an innovative way then great
if he can't then i think we still have a
problem and you know it has been a
problem with a lot of the other
literature in neural networks that you
can't really do that so
there are a few representations there
tree rnns and
stuff like that that sure have had
explicit representations of trees and
things like that but by and large
a typical thing is like a large language
model where you can't recover the parts
um
so i was playing yesterday with
something called um proofwriter
which is really interesting system by
peter clark and some other people at
allen ai
and sometimes it does very well and
other times it does pretty poor so i
took a example from from the entailment
literature which is like ames is a
clever spy and then you ask it is ames a
spy and you should be able to make that
inference and it says no and you know i
don't know exactly why it said no and
and the kind of hallmark of these
systems you never know this one's
actually better at being able to
list intermediate steps in its inference
but you still don't really get a sense
of why it failed on that if you had a
proper compositional system you should
be able to derive that yeah and
so can you help me understand why is it
so important to be able to recover the
parts because for example in neural
networks they gain a lot of their power
by by being able to do if they have
power by being able to do this
entanglement right where they can kind
of share representational states across
different
and i'm going to use the term loosely
here categories but i'm just wondering
suppose i had a a system
and let's assume that it isn't just a
matter of definition to be compositional
that you can recover the parts but
what's the practical importance of being
able to to recover the parts
so so let me first insert sharing is
good i mean you want to have
representations that you can share
across systems i mean in the old days of
neural networks there was no sharing of
anything and then people figured out
like how you could at least like take
off the last layer and put on a new last
layer so you're sharing the internal
representations sharing is good of
course symbolic systems are all about
sharing i have some common database
store and then i have apis that can call
it and so on there is no way to agi
without being able to have shared
representations and hinton's glom is
another okay you know approach to shared
representation so so that part is
essential it's necessary on anybody's
approach and i i think without it we're
in trouble um so then the question is
like
more like interpretability and
recoverability and i think i just gave
you an example so um if i read the
sentence aim was was a clever spy i
should be able to now tell you what he
did for a living right
um
you know i should be able to
you know it was a clever spy or a lousy
spy either way i infer that he's a spy
because the sentence structure of it is
ames i mean let's say sort of chomsky
analysis ames was and then we got a noun
phrase there and i don't know the head
of it is is spy there's different ways
to talk about it there's an adjective
modify if i have that structure then you
know
on any reasonable semantics it falls out
um
that aims with a clever spine now
another place where this really matters
and nobody has a good solution kind of
on tap is negation so
um
you know these systems
allison editor did some nice work on
this some other people have hers it was
with bird but it's still generally an
issue um
if i say something like john is alive
and john is not alive you should
understand those as really being
different and you should be able to
derive that from the compositional
structure and from understanding
quantifiers um and negation words like
not um and if all you have is a whole
then you can wind up with weird
phenomena like the sentence is john is
alive and john is not alive might be
closer together in space than um those
two sentences are to john eats jelly
beans um but you want to actually be
able to
have a system that's so clever that it
can infer from john eats jelly beans
that he is alive and can infer from john
is not alive that that john right that
the sentence john is alive is false and
you need to have some fluidity about
working across those parts
well i wanted to put something to you
gary so one thing we've been thinking
about we had a wonderful conversation
with randall balestrio and he painted
this picture of neural networks as being
a little bit like a decomposition method
so you decompose the the euclidean
ambient space up into these little
polyhedra and all of the neurons
basically form faces of the cells in
that polyhedra so it's it's that you can
kind of think of them as locality
sensitive hashing tables much like many
other machine learning algorithms like
decision trees also carve up the input
space nearest neighbor does as well so
so that's an interesting first thought
and then the second thought is well how
do they extrapolate at all well
inductive priors essentially they create
space junk they they kind of replicate
copies of the information all over that
ambient space so it becomes interpretive
data augmentation does the same thing
it's creating more space junk so the the
difference between reasoning as we know
it gary and the neural network seems to
be like reasoning i think of as being a
kind of search or discovery process and
neural networks i think of as being more
of a memorization process and we can
only cheat by kind of creating this
space junk all over the ambient space i
mean is that a good way of thinking
about it in your view
well
you can certainly think of reasoning as
a search process what to me is essential
is that it's an algebraic process
um let me come back to that in one
second and first say yes i think the
neural networks are basically
memorization devices they're not
literal direct table lookup they're much
more sophisticated than that but like
there's a really nice result um i wish i
could say the the first author's name um
that i tweeted about last week maybe put
it in the show notes that looked at
arithmetic um i think samir singh is the
senior author on yeah i i've invited him
on he's coming on in a couple of weeks
um
can i can i just frame that up actually
because that's beautiful um after our
gpt free conversation we had this um
notion in our mind didn't we gary that
it's just memorizing the input data and
and um
the folks said oh well look it's it's
memorizing
sorry it's it's producing really good
results one shot on these multiplication
tables but what these folks did now that
gptj has been released the data set is
publicly available so now you can do
some really interesting look-ups between
you know this location
it's yeah i mean it's a loiter's data
not gbt3's data um oh that that's right
that's right so it's gbt jade um
released by aloyfa
exactly but but it's it's a what it's a
wonderful situation that um olofer did
release that exactly it's fantastic so
so when when you plot the accuracy
against the current statistics in the
data set it's a linear graph and then um
they just changed so the x-axis was um
these the second component of the
multiplication and you would expect
similar numbers to be very close
together on that graph but they weren't
they were very far apart which was i
think very strong evidence that the
model was just memorizing the data set
exactly i i thought there was a really
important study i tweeted as you know
super important um
and i mean there are other things that
have pointed in that direction and in
fact i anticipated this years and years
ago um if if you know if i have a chip
on my shoulder it's that in 1998 i said
these things are basically just
memorizing and not extrapolating
and i was
attacked i may have told you this before
for
um somebody characterized that as a
terrorist attack on connectionism um
pointing this out i used an example of
the identity function to make points
very actually similar to to the recent
result and that hasn't changed in 20
some years and people should well anyway
i know but i wanted to put another thing
to you because we were talking about um
self-driving cars earlier and to me it
seems completely obvious what we're
talking about when you have this
open-ended domain and you have a
combinatorial explosion of possible
compositions you have all of these
low-frequency
attributes if you like on the long tail
you're literally trying to memorize
infinity
yeah isaac i mean look it's an empirical
question it's a with driverless cars
it's an empirical question um it might
not be infinity it might be some very
large number and like i wouldn't want to
say there's no way it's going to work
but you know empirically we can see that
throwing more data is not really
fundamentally changing the outlier
problem so you know it's a large number
it's not infinity but it looks to be
really really large um and you know it's
not clear that the scaling works we
could talk about scaling laws in a
second i've been thinking about a bunch
of them but let's let's go back to the
other question um which is what is the
reasoning stuff and why do i call it
algebraic um even though there is an
element of search in reasoning right
you're searching different ways you
could prove something you know that's
very valid but the part that to me is
even more core is the extrapolation is
algebraic so what i mean by that is like
you haven't a rule in algebra like y
equals x plus two so you have a variable
or actually two variables y and x you
have operations plus and equals um and
then you can substitute arbitrary things
into your equation so i think i said y
equals x plus 2 maybe was a thing so so
now if i make x 5 then i can calculate
for y the corresponding value and i can
do that over an infinite class of some
things so i could define it to be over
integers or real numbers or you know
what have you um but that's how algebra
works and i think that's how reasoning
works is you can do things over
essentially unbounded classes like this
is going to be true for all animals or
all people or
you know all left-handed people or
whatever so you have some class that
you're bounded to and then you can do it
across all of them multiplication is
like that but in the system that we just
talked about your gpt doing
multiplication
you don't get this phenomena where i can
do it equally well for all instances of
a class you get something where it's
very similarity dependent um my
graduate school work with stephen pinker
was about language and had exactly the
same phenomena we looked at irregular
verbs and regular verbs and what we
found was that children's over
regularizations for the irregular verbs
were very dependent on frequency um but
if if you gave them um
sorry the correct irregulars would
depend on frequency but but they could
over regularize anything of any sound
because there was a general rule that
could operate freely
is these rules that operate freely that
you don't really have a clean
representation of in a transformer model
in a transformer model you tend to
emulate them so you emulate
arithmetic with respect to the known
cases and cross your fingers for the
rest can you imagine me shipping a
microprocessor where you had to cross
your fingers for some multiplication
problems like this
people think about the pentium and they
got all upset that there was a bug and
it's like
one in a trillion operations was off by
a bid or whatever and then you've got
this thing that's like off like half the
time on ordinary arithmetic and you have
100 billion dollars of research funding
in the thing that's wrong half the time
on you know most arithmetic problem like
so let me okay
uh
i want to dive just a bit on this
extrapolation versus i'm assuming the
opposite of that is interpolation
because we did have as we mentioned you
know ian lacoon and randall balashriero
on and they made a they made a point
which in some ways is very compelling
which is
if you define extrapolation kind of in
the very classic linear
way which is that
you know if i've got all my observed
data there's a convex hall that contains
all that data and if a new data point is
outside that convex hall by definition
it's extrapolation
okay they go from that and i agree
that's kind of a perhaps an i.e
definition of it but it's a definition
if you then add in the cursive
dimensionality so now you have you know
1024 dimensional data because it's
images or or something like that
it's almost always going to be
extrapolation you're always going to
have data points the new data points are
going to lie outside that convex hall
and they made the argument that hey this
means neural networks are always
extrapolating and look how well they
work so i guess my question to you is
what's a what's a more useful definition
of extrapolation versus interpolation
that doesn't just fall apart in very
high dimension
i'm not sure the perfect definition
there the first thing i would say though
is these are the old groucho marx mine
who are you going to believe me or your
own lion eyes um
if you look at what these systems
actually do they're clearly still
struggling with extrapolation so
like for example a proof writer you know
it works up to a point or for example
the multiplication system uh from samir
singh's lab um same thing it works up to
a point and it's clearly not so like
empirically these systems are not
extrapolating and there's an important
point here the function that a person
would be um
extrapolated so they're not i don't
think they're extrapolating at all well
but i'm asking for addition if you look
at the convex
notion
there's some you know room for
definitional haggling
and
um i have to think about their
definition but
when it comes down to it what i'm
interested in are these operations that
people can do fluidly i mean
multiplication's not perfect people
actually have some trouble but certainly
that machines and principle could do
fluently so you know there are
tens of billions of pocket calculators
and computers that can perfectly
extrapolate the multiplication they're
not even doing it as extrapolation
they're just defining to do it over a
full class um it's exactly but but
gary's but that that is that is
performing a computation neural network
says as i was just saying and there are
inductive priors and it's their
responsibility to create space junk
everywhere so even if you wanted to
extrapolate the sine function
you would need to create an inductive
prior to basically create space
outside of the training range to it
would be specific every single time so
that the cnn prior creates the space
junk everywhere there's no way of doing
it without creating the space junk
i mean that's their only means right
they use what you're calling space junk
to um kind of emulate functions right
and
they invariably
well that's probably too strong in many
many cases
the space junk strategy doesn't really
suffice for outlier cases you know in
when you compare to a microprocessor
doing multiplication there is no notion
of an outlier case it's just you know
within these bounds i will get the right
answer and this is why you want some
things to be done with symbolic
operations is because you can define
them so that you're not at the mercy of
in my training set i happen to have this
example
one of the reasons i love what a leuther
is doing is because exactly these
questions need to be answered how much
is memorization how how
sensitive are you to the training set
and the sameer singh uh studies you know
a good example of that that kind of test
and you know the answer is pretty clear
you can see it on the other end um
the people are talking about now the
data leakage problem well the data
leakage problem is basically the system
is mimicking you know your credit card
number or whatever it finds in the
database the background the cow it finds
everything with grass as cows because
all the cows had a green green
background i think that's a separate but
related uh kind of issue and i love the
snowplow
you know the school bus in a field of
snow that they describe as a snow plow
um
and i mean there it's what it's telling
you is is that what the system really
cares about is the texture not the
abstract concept that a person would
care about so you mentioned you
mentioned earlier um you had some
commentary on scaling scaling laws yeah
could you could you go into that yeah um
it was this very clever paper by kaplan
at all at openai that's i think got a
lot of people excited which says that
there are scaling laws for large
language models and i think there are a
few remarks to make about them
um
first what are they for
your you know in case your listeners
viewers haven't seen them before there
are these nice neat lines the original
ones were showing you know the bigger
your model the better that you're able
basically to memorize the training set
it didn't use those words right um
the obvious it was i mean it could have
turned out that you might not have found
that like there'd be saturation function
that's actually part of one i want to
talk about um but
could you comment on that though because
you know we said there's this
combinatorial space of possibilities so
it's not going to saturate is it have i
have i understood that correctly
i don't actually quite know the limits
um and there's some interaction with
data and having enough unique data is is
the saturation limited by the um the
training benchmark no no there is no
saturation here so on the training on
those original results there was no
saturation yeah
that's right so
in the original just so everybody's on
the same page there was no saturation
there were nice functions nice clean
functions where you could basically
predict things and there'd been a bunch
of things like that but here's what they
left out well actually first let's talk
about a rhetorical trick so they call
them scaling laws and they're not
actually laws
they're not laws in the sense of
laws of the physical universe they're
really empirical observations that have
held under some regime for some tasks
right
and then that raises the question of
under what other regimes and what are
the tasks so you know mastering your
training set is one thing but
generalizing on some other task let's
say about common sense is another and
you know we're already
in 2022 and there's still you know
bigger models to be made finding some
evidence of saturation where some of the
models reach a point of diminishing
returns
um i saw evidence of this on a kind of
moral reasoning task from anthropic that
was just published deep mind has some
papers recently that kind of point in
this direction and then there's also um
they used to call it decollage and the
piagetian community when when things
separate so um and it was a kind of
embarrassing thing to admit in the
piaget community because it's supposed
to be everything moved in stair steps
and so when something didn't you had to
say well that's decology whatever that
really meant my theory is wrong um and
so there there is decollage here so some
tasks really are scaling and others not
so much nobody has the perfect
comprehension task but i would say if we
did i think it's hard because it would
require a lot of hand work by humans we
really had a task does this system
comprehend things i would say there's
been you know at most linear increase
that's very very modest and we're
basically on the floor still in terms of
having a system actually understand
language um that's not scaling anything
like the rate of memorizing a training
set
um as a function of model size so
there's already evidence that like
common sense is not really improving at
the same rate and you know
ai safety is measured in various ways
it's not really scaling at the same rate
there's evidence that some things
actually get worse like bias in one of
the senses in which we use it there may
actually get get worse get bigger um as
you scale the model um and you know the
problem with bias is you're perpetuating
past history so you get better at
perpetuating the past history but that's
in opposition of what you actually want
to achieve you want you know a just
society that doesn't just perpetuate
past history um maybe that's too much of
a digression but the bottom line is
they're not absolute laws it's kind of
like you know moore's law was operating
for a while but you know some people
think in the last 15 years it's slowed
down just because it's true for a while
doesn't mean it's true forever and even
if you made some argument that moore's
law is still operative nobody thinks
it's going to go infinitely the way i
would put it is
there are some things that you would
expect the models to get better and
fundamentally they're just predicting
the next word and you know no surprise
that if you give them more capacity to
memorize um that they're going to get
better at that the real question is is
that going to help you on the full range
of things that you need to know and
predicting the next word is like a tiny
piece of what we need to do for language
the remarkable discovery is that gets
you to like eighty percent on a lot of
things but it typically does not get to
it a hundred percent on anything useful
other than auto completion
and so all the other things you might
want to do maybe they don't scale as
well and then you might have a problem
so the empirical question here i think
for driving as an example is you have a
whole industry that's actually
predicated on the belief in scaling laws
people didn't make that explicit but
that's been the operative assumption for
at least
half a decade a little bit longer than
half a decade and so there's been
enormous investment in scaling the data
and also in scaling the models and there
are really two things that you could
talk about scaling um and they the guess
that people are making is that if i
scale the model big enough and i scale
the data big enough i will solve the
outlier problem right that's an
empirical guess about scaling and we're
already talking about this a few minutes
ago it might not work that way it might
be that there's just too much of a
periphery and you you start to asymptote
and you're screwed and then you know it
could turn out that we put in like 50
billion dollars across society on the
premise that scaling is going to get you
there and that it doesn't and we have to
go back to the drawing board and build
richer cognitive models and who knows
what i think these may actually just be
artifacts of the fact that we're doing
all the time
max the the equivalent of maximum
likelihood estimation you know they're
sitting here training neural networks to
just maximize the likelihood of a
particular class there's no effort to do
any type of marginalization or any type
of quantification of the density of the
you know the uncertain density of those
estimations and i saw somebody um i
forget what tim what was that paper that
had like the the super
super scaling law thing or whatever was
that called where um you know the longer
you trained it the longer you trained at
crooking huh
at clocking the one where the validation
lost suddenly
flied up after a long time right and
there's there's at least from my
perspective i saw somebody making a very
compelling argument that that's just an
artifact of the fact that they're not
doing
marginalization over over the
predictions but they're just looking at
maximum likelihood and it's really just
oh sorry you mean double decent double
december yeah the double descent it's
more just a behavior of that particular
estimator than it is of anything else so
let me just uh i'll i'll make this more
precise and give you the reference so
the paper is called bayesian deep
learning and a probabilistic perspective
on generalization by wilson and
ismalov and and the point that they make
in there was that this observation of
some of these double descent or you know
grokking and things like that are an
artifact of the fact that you're finding
a best fit model just a particular
neural network you're finding that best
fit model and looking at its behavior
rather than looking at the uncertain
population of all possible
neural networks and they they found that
if you do this bayesian model averaging
the phenomenon disappears it's like
you're just looking at an average
behavior versus a maximum likelihood
behavior you get very different scaling
laws
that's interesting yeah please send it
to me yeah we'll do
awesome
well professor gary marcus it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you so much for
coming on thanks a lot for having me
amazing